Hello everyone, everything good
Hello My Name Is Andrew
power is our technician's
fleece for bruno
the phantom of the opera and our dani
designer then power up is a service
that the academies can offer their
students to better motivate them and keep
their attention in the gym is a
very difficult for academies to believe
nowadays face what it is to keep
students engaged and motivated within
from that space then power the clamp to
exactly close everything cute
What we do is a service that the
teachers can create
students directly at Claudia and the
students through their cell phones
use of service directly in the
gym equipment
it's like he's arriving with a cell phone and
without the appliance.
bringing within it is of that package
all 1 of all the elements of
identification necessary to motivate
the
that is we have challenges book borges is
actively and many other elements that
help this student to maintain
motivated full time
imagine that the student arrives at the academy and
drug in an exercise such as leg press
he will be challenged to show that the
His friend is picking up a little bit bigger
and he will, I'll try finally
Next week, next week, keep coming.
Who only thinks he went all these days?
but in the following month he earns 50
discount
this is the poet but at the same time the
academies has an entire system of
statistics on the use of that space
for me to make better decisions and
many other systems to help them
to organize your space better take the
better decisions
keep their students always engaged and
You can only wait.